طبعا عمليه ازاله الانقاض او
الدمار في المواقع التي ضربها البلدان
مستمره لم تتوقف ابدا
خلال الليله الماضيه وساعات المساء يوم
امس الاثنين وطبعا المتوقع ان تستمر
لاعاده الوان لانها حجم الدمار كبير
وبالتالي يعني طالما ان هناك
كتل خرسانيه قد سقطت بفعل الزلزال هذا
يعني هذه الكتل هناك
عالقون ربما تستطيع
السلطات والطرق الانقاذ انقاذ الوصول
اليهم وانقاذ حياتهم في حال كانوا على قيد
الحياه طبعا لذلك العمليات ستستمر لعده
ايام لكن مع استمرار هذه العمليات من
المفترض وصول المزيد
من اطقم الانقاذ لدعم عمليات انقاذ
الحكومه التركيه بحاجه لاضعاف الاشخاص
الذين يعملون الان في هذا الموضوع موضوع
ازاله الانقاذ يوم امس كان الحديث من قبل
رئيس هيئه
الطوارئ والكوارث التركيه افاد عن تطوع او
انضمام اكثر من خمسين الف شخص الى
كوادر المؤسسه للمساعده في عمليات الدعم
لكن لا يعلم ان كان كل هذا العدد هو
سيشارك فيه
الانقاب ام سيشارك في موضوع مثلا الاهتمام
بما مراكز الايواء او اهتمام
في مراكز الايواء لذلك تركيا بحاجه الى
نستطيع القول فرق انقاذ متخصصه وهذا ما
يبدو انه يعني بدا يصل تباعا عن طريق
اذربيجان
[موسيقى]
الفريقان ومكون من 370 شخص وصلوا مساء
الاثنين وايضا
الفرق الاخرى التي ستباعا الى تركيا اعتبا
او ربما وصل بعضها الليله الماضي لنبدا
حتى الان الحكومه التركيه
لم تعلن رسميا عن اسماء
الفرق او الدول او اسماء الفرق التي وصلت
لشركه الى تركيا وباشرت عملها من فضلك
تحديثات هذا اليوم
لكن بالعموم حتى تفصل هذه الفرق بشكل امن
وسريع الى المناطق المدمره تتطلب على
الحكومه التركيه فتح الطرق التي انهار
بعضها وهذا فعلا ما شاهدناه يوم امس تحاول
السلطات التركيه فتح اعاده فتح الطرق او
ترميم بعض الطرق التي دمرت بسبب الزلزال
حتى يتسنى لسرقه الانقاذ سواء الانقاذ
التي وصلت من خارج البلاد او حتى
الانقاذ المحليه الموجوده في الولايات
الاخرى والذي ترغب بالوصول الى المنا